in this time things are changing
dramatically my own view in the United
States it is the inequality that has led
us here it isn't
and certainly the elite have benefited
from that but we also have in the u.s. a
political class that is completely out
of touch in my view with the American
people an O and an ethos in Washington
that is very power centric fueled by
legally corrupt money that have in their
main in their main goal is to stay in
power and and I've seen it then this
isn't the last three years I've watched
this grow over the course of certainly
the last 20 or so when I was in
Washington and I think that is at the
core of the resentment on the part of
the people united states that
disappearance of what we used to call
the American dream where everybody sort
of had an equal shot and the complete
lack of accountability we've heard
accountability multiple times here the
complete lack of accountability on the
part of anybody in a position of power I
grew up in a world in which income
inequality in my country Canada's and I
think the United States is saying very
sharply compressed there's a period
between 45 and 1973 when income
inequality basically keeps reproducing
the pattern of compressed inequality
that we saw in the Depression and the
Second World War and my parents
generation came back from the Second
World War professionals in in in in in
their fields deeply affected by the
Solidarity of the Second World War
emotionally affected by a sense that
we're all in this together my father my
mother had this passionate sense as
liberals that it was one Society we were
going to build it we're going to rebuild
it I think we and then from the 70s
onwards the numbers are remorseless we
begin to see an upward tick in in a call
we don't understand all of its drivers
some of its new technology some of its
self dealing some of its liberal
professions doing better out of the
economy and than they really should I
mean there's some self dealing there's
some technological change but it has
fractured I think you're quite right
it's fracture of the society a glaring
moral dilemma will at some point emerge
have you know having to do with global
inequality and so say you're you're
sitting in a hotel bar and you decide to
order a bottle of wine for 100 euros to
after a busy day and in the time that it
takes for the bottle of wine to arrive
on your phone you can research through
vaccinations in the third world or
something of this nature how much it
would cost statistically to save one
human life and say it turns out to be
also around 100 euros and what do you do
do you say I'm just gonna put this out
of my mind because I want to drink the
bottle of wine or which would you know
be by any standard in the moral decision
or do you accept that this you know sort
of the state of perfect information
we're going into that gives you this
kind of information at your fingertips
wherever you are you accept that I'm not
going to ignore this and I'm gonna sort
of press the one-click button on my on
my charity app and not and you know have
you know just like a glass of water
instead and if once you do accept that
though then you're really on a slippery
slope basically because where does it
end
over the last 3040 years one of the
challenges has been as the wall came
down and the new world has emerged is
that Western countries have become more
like feudal States because the
incentives for elite to acquire wealth
and position of power and to retain
those have meant that right now
according to research done in Sweden in
the United Kingdom and the USA and
Holland will not be far behind the
chances of you staying if you're born in
the bottom 20% are significantly higher
than if you're born today in Sierra
Leone or Nisha or Kazakhstan and that
means that you have a trap where the
people are poorest in society will start
to make demands about the fact that they
are not being heard and those demands
could head towards the heart left
with perfectly good reason or towards
the hard right in the ban and who is
talking about things that are real you
know in equality Israel the elites are
not listening they are failing you and
that's why it's so dangerous we should
be paying a great deal of attention to
why it is that we in the West think
we're at a loose end because as far as
I'm concerned Afghanistan Iraq and
certain countries around the world and
not excluded but I feel a great deal
safer today than I did as a child of the
Cold War where every Friday at my school
we had a drill to hide under a table in
case there was a nuclear attack where we
had three day weeks and energy shortages
we had problems about food supply you
know we had the PLO we had ad aircraft
hijackings all the time you know are the
safety of our world and the prosperity
we've come to take for granted because
we have no perspective right and if you
don't pay attention to history and in my
particular view not just European
history in the history of the West but
to this much bigger picture then you
lose the ability to look in the right
direction so the West is at a crossroads
for this reason